[Music]
the evil wizard mole de Voort has been
trying to kill you for years and today
it looks like he's going to succeed but
your friends are on their way and if you
can survive until they arrive they
should be able to help stop him
the evil Wizards protective charms ward
off every spell you know so in an act of
desperation you throw the only object in
reach at him
Pythagoras cursed chess board it works
but with a catch mold of wart starts in
one corner of the 5x5 Borg you have a
few minutes to choose four distinct
positive whole numbers mole de Voort
gets to say one of them and if you can
pick a square on the board whose center
is exactly that distance away the curse
will force him to move to that spot then
he'll have to choose any of the four
numbers and the process repeats until
you can't keep him inside the board with
legal moves then he'll break free of the
spell and almost certainly kill you what
four numbers can you choose to keep mole
de Voort trapped by your spell long
enough for help to arrive and what's
your strategy
the trick here is to keep mold of wart
where you want him and one way to figure
out how to do that is to play out the
game as mold of wart would always trying
to escape you're dealing with a
relatively small board so the numbers
can't be too big let's start by trying 1
2 3 4 to see what happens
mold of wart could escape those numbers
in just 3 moves by saying 2 then 3 he
would force you to let him into one of
the middle points of the grid and then a
4 would break him free but that means
you'll need to allow a number larger
than 4 which is the distance from one
end of a row to another how is that even
possible through diagonal moves there
are in fact points that are distance 5
from each other which we know thanks to
the Pythagorean theorem that states that
the squares of the sides of a right
triangle add up to the square of its
hypotenuse one of the most famous
Pythagorean triples is 3 4 5 and that
triangle is hiding all over your chess
board so if mold of wart was here and he
said 5 you could move him to these
spaces there's another insight that will
help the board is very symmetrical if
mold of wart is in a corner it doesn't
really matter to you which corner it is
so we can think of the corners as being
functionally the same and color them all
blue similarly the spaces neighboring
the corners behave the same as each
other and we'll make them red finally
the midpoints of the sides are a third
type so instead of having to develop a
strategy for each of the 16 spaces on
the outside of the board we can reduce
the problem to just three meanwhile all
the inside spaces are bad for us because
if mold afford ever reaches one he'll be
able to say any number larger than 3 and
go free
orange spaces are trouble too since any
number except 1 2 or 4 would take him to
an inside space or off the board so
orange is out and you'll need to keep
him on blue and
that means two is bad since it could
take mole de Voort to orange on the
first turn but the for other smallest
numbers one three four and five might
work let's try them and see what happens
if mole de fort says one you can make
him go from blue to red or red to blue
and the same works if he says three
thanks to our diagonals this is even
true if he says five if he says four you
can keep him on the color he's already
on by moving the length of a row or
column so these four numbers work even
if your friends don't get here right
away
you'll be able to keep the world's most
evil wizard contained for as long as you
need
while you wait why not use the time to
prepare yourself for future duels of
wits and wisdom by using brilliant
brilliance website and app featured
dozens of courses in math logic science
and computer science no matter what your
stem goals are whether you want to hone
your riddle skills learn to program or
brush up your scientific know-how
brilliant has tools and resources for
you visit brilliant org slash ted-ed to
try it out as a bonus the first eight
hundred thirty three of you to use that
link will receive 20% off the annual
premium subscription fee
[Music]